for the first time President Trump says
American consumers not China could pay a
price for his ongoing trade war the
president has decided to delay potential
new tariffs on billions of dollars worth
of Chinese goods
wheatridge Aang is traveling with the
president who was at his New Jersey Golf
Club today which a big question now what
does this decision mean for US companies
and consumers oh good morning Gail this
is good news because it means that
tariffs are not driving up the prices of
some of the most popular goods from
China but the relief is temporary and
it's unclear if delaying the tariffs
will actually help facilitate a
permanent trade deal they ripped off our
country for years President Trump didn't
back off from his usual attacks against
China Tuesday even as he backed down on
new tariffs against its imports
[Music]
the administration delayed a 10% tariff
on about 300 billion dollars of Chinese
goods to December 15th so cell phones
laptops video game consoles shoes some
toys and clothing will not be taxed
until then economists say it would have
cost the average American household an
extra 270 dollars a year and would have
been in addition to the 25% tariff
already in place on 250 billion dollars
of Chinese imports
[Music]
but it was actually American industries
that had to pay the fees for Chinese
products consumer groups pressured the
administration to hold off on more
tariffs because corporations will
eventually have to pass the costs to
customers Apple CEO Tim Cook spoke with
Norah O'Donnell in June the truth is the
iPhone is made everywhere it's made
everywhere and so a tariff on the iPhone
would hurt all of those countries but
the one that would be hurt the most is
is this is this one
i thik stonefish is a senior fellow at
the asia society center on us-china
relation it's been very unpredictable
for businesses in America and for
consumers and businesses globally having
different prices having different tariff
announcements come and go makes it
really difficult to plan a president
Trump said the calls with China were
very productive but this move does not
offer any relief to those farmers still
hurting from retaliatory tariffs and as
his reelection campaign ramps up the
president has every reason to try to end
this trade war for hard hat bread Vout
states like Iowa especially before the
caucuses Tony all right Lygia thank you
very much